KEY ONE, ON YOUR TOES, THE BLUE
JACKETS WANT TO START THIS QUICK
AND BE READY.
PUSH YOUR PACE,
FRONT.
PERFECT PLAY THERE BY ANDREW
PEEKE WHO
THE NET, IT WAS DEFLECTED AND
THERE'S ELVIS WIT ELVIS'S VIEW
MAROON, YOU CAN'T SLIENOW HE DO
OF COREY PERRY TOUCHING HIS
SHOULDAYS NO.
IT WAS A GREAT PLAY AND IT WAS
GAVRIKOV THAT GOT HISCOLTON.
NOW
CORNER FOR VORACEK.
CERNAK BIG
HE BATTLES THROUGH.
NOW JOHNSON HERE, THIS IS WHY
VORACEK HAS SUCH AN OPPORTUNITY.
>> Jody: LOOKS LIKE A
GROUP THAT CARES WITH EACH OTHER
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT IF
HE'S HAD A GOOD FIRST PERIOD.
>>
FROM THE SHARP ANGLE, HE GETS A
QUALITY SHOT.
ELLIOTT TRIED T FIRST THREE MIN
THIS GAME JUST PUTTING PUCKS IN
ON ELLIOTT T
CLIP HE'S PLAYING ATERE, OH, BJD
GETS RIGHT BACK UP.
HE GOT HIT HARD THERE AND HERE
SETTLED IN BUT THIS LINE COMES
OUT AND GETS TO WORK A AGOAL.
HE HAS WON
THIS PLAY UP.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN GUS NYQUIST.
AND THEY'RE STILL LAUGHING ABOUT
IT.
GOING TO FORCE THE
GREAT WORK, ESPECIALLY ACK ON
IT.
CROSS ICE IN FRONT, OH, WHAT A
STOP THERE BY ELVIS MERZLIKINS
WITH POWER PLAY
GOAL WEAVES HIS WAY ACROSS THE
LINE, WHIPS IT AROUND THE
BOARDS.
CUT OFBJORKSTRAND WHIPS IT AROU.
BEAN.
CLNIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE STINGER IN THERE
AWAY, PICKED UP
HERE BY PAUL.
OF THAT RIGHT BACKER, YOU CAN S
WORKS THE GOAL LINE, NOW HE BRA
PICK IT UP.
LESS THAN 2:00 TO THIS ONE AND
CROWD APPRECIATES IT BATTLE
TESTED YEA